ich verrate ihnen zum reinkommen direkt
mal ein gut gehütetes geheimnis noch
genau 70 tage und wir sind die groko los
ja wir haben es extra nachgerechnet am
sechsten dezember beginnt der
spd-parteitag und spätestens dann sagt
die sozen basis leise servus
ja klar das muss die es für die am ende
natürlich selbst entscheiden wir wollen
die da nicht irgendwie unter druck
setzen das steht uns gar nicht zu aber
ich bin mir da wirklich hundertprozentig
relativ sicher meine damen und herren am
nikolaus ist groko aus ja und da darf
man schon mal fragen als was wird angela
merkel denn in die geschichte eingehen
als klimakanzlerin schon mal nicht da
ist es sicher nachdem die groko dieses
pseudo klimaschutzpaket rausgehauen hat
wobei sie selber waren glaube ich
relativ zufrieden mit sich deswegen bin
ich auf dieses paket sehr stolz und darf
nicht bei allen bedanken und das sage
ich auch noch mal als csu-vorsitzender
ein dankeschön
aber ich will nicht darf wer sehr sehr
herzlich bedanken ich wollte mich dafür
auch ganz herzlich bedanken auch mein
persönlicher dank an alle ich dafür kann
man sich bei allen zu bedanken
dafür bedanke ich nicht auch noch mal
sehr herzlich also nochmal vielen dank
dafür
bitteschön
[Applaus]
die ersten 30 in afrika gingen für tank
drauf im streit über zu viel oder zu
wenig klimaschutz hat sich die groko wie
immer instinktiv für den arsch teuren
mittelweg entschieden mit dem wir unsere
ziele aber trotzdem verfehlen jetzt
streichen sie aus dieser kompromiss
geburt auch noch die konkreten co2
zahlen die jede maßnahme einsparen soll
streichen sie raus aber das finale
argument gegen das klimapaket ist diese
pressemitteilung der verband der
deutschen automobilindustrie findet
super ja
kurz gesagt das klimapaket kann man
verbrennen geht aber nicht wegen
feinstaub so alle klima schädlichen
subventionen wie für diesel oder
dienstwagen bleiben die pendlerpauschale
wird sogar erhöht damit weniger leute
auto fahren aber hauptsache alle jetten
schön zum klimagipfel nach new york zwei
maschinen der flugbereitschaft machen
sich startklar
fast zeitgleich heben die kanzlerin und
die verteidigungsministerin ab beide mit
dem ziel usa aber jede für sich
selbstverständlich jede für sich
man will auch ein bisschen privatsphäre
sonst kannst du gleich mit easyjet
fliegen oder aber verstehen sie
eigentlich was für eine sensation sie da
gerade gehört haben
die flugbereitschaft der bundesregierung
hat er zwei funktionierende flugzeuge
gleichzeitig
[Applaus]
seit jahren nicht mehr
annegret und angela reisen mit zwei
flieger in die usa
man muss es aber auch ein bisschen
verstehen denn ich sage mal ehrlich wer
mal irgendeine hkk rede ganz gehört hat
und das erträgt du keine sieben stunden
ja ja da hat die frau merkel halt mal
schlechte erfahrungen gemacht
die erste etappe ist die sogenannte
zuhör tour
sie wird starten am 27
april abends in konstanz die tournatur
ist konzipiert ganz kompakt auf eine
zeit bis zweieinhalb monate das heißt
bis mitte juli
in dieser zeit wird es 40 vor ort
termine geben mit den unterschiedlichen
verbänden hinzu kommen noch gesonderte
gespräche
[Applaus]
die fans verstehen
andererseit selber schuld merkel sie hat
die fettnapf königin noch zu ihrer
nachfolgerin ernannt
wie kann man sich feiern für das was in
diesen 19 stunden klimaverhandlungen
rausgekommen ist wie kann man hier echte
entlarvende bilder nicht von uns
bearbeitet von der entscheidenden nacht
in berlin
die haben da nebenbei schön fußball
geguckt ja peter altmaier ist mehrfach
zur tanke gefahren und hat erdnussflips
gekommen es kennt europa league lief da
eintrags frankfurt gegen arsenal am ende
also eine schlimme niederlage für
frankfurt und fürs klima und alles in
allem ein klarer fall von böswillig
vorgetäuschter klimapolitik herzlich
willkommen bei politiker detektivs
[Musik]
berlin die soko klima ist einer
mysteriösen hochstaplerin auf der spur
die seit jahren in verschiedene
identitäten schlüpft mal gibt sie sich
als tischlerin aus dann als
schlagzeugerin der puhdys ein anderes
mal als erfolglose windpark betreiberin
jetzt ihr neuester coup
zusammen mit diesen sieben komplizen
präsentiert angela m ein sogenanntes
klimaschutzpaket eine spurensuche 1995
sagt diese blutjungen umweltministerin
folgen der klimaänderung werden uns alle
betreffen
zwölf jahre später meint diese kanzlerin
wenn wir das richtige tun
energieeinsparen co2 emissionen
vermeiden dass wir dann auch eine gute
chance haben das thema zu bewältigen
noch mal zwölf jahre später hat eine
ganz andere kanzlerin was gehört wir
alle haben den weckruf der jugend gehört
toll und jetzt das unglaubliche erproben
beweisen bei den drei frauen handelt es
sich um ein und dieselbe person
seither regiert hat deutschland alle
klimaziele versammelt angela m wohnt
seit jahren in dieser sozialwohnung nur
einen kilometer entfernt stirbt 2011 der
süße eisbär knut zufall
ja schon aber wie weitere angela m loch
gehen um das klima nicht zu retten
von schuldbewusstsein jedenfalls keine
spur dafür nicht
[Musik]
kubicki
es wird kein beschluss so die frage
bleibt was wird merkels politisches
vermächtnis klima nicht haben wir
gelernt europa ich sag mal wenn man
einen gewissen herrn makro fragt auch er
noch aufschwung klar aufschwung hatten
wir gar keine frage xxl aber dann kommt
man sich ein foto von irgend einer
beliebigen stadt im ruhrgebiet an und
denkt ach so ja
allein die deutschen kommunen schieben
einen investitionsstau von 159
milliarden vor sich her
also ausgerechnet da wo bürger wirklich
auf staat trifft leben wir oft nur von
der substanz trotz all der fetten jahre
wir fallen in so vielen bereichen
gnadenlos zurück hier haben sie das
gesehen in peking eröffnet der
flächenmäßig größte flughafen der welt
nach gerade mal vier jahren bauzeit das
machen die chinesen nur uns zu demütigen
vier jahre solange dort das bei uns bist
ein verlorenes gepäck wiederfinden aber
gut und vielleicht sind wir auch ein
bisschen zu harte in unserem urteil über
die kanzlerin
wichtig ist ja dass ihre parteifreunde
von ihr begeistert sind
in der rückschau wird man über kanzlerin
merkel sagen dass sie ziemlich land
brigitte unglaublich warmherzige merkel
laudatio von jens fahren am nikolaus ist
kroko aus ich lege mich fest nicht mehr
lange hin
deswegen wird in merkels
brandenburgische heimatstadt templin
weil das passende museum eröffnet für
uns vor ort wirte schneider wird ist es
denn schön geworden super ein
angemessenes denkmal für die ära merkel
man merkt da haben sich leute richtig
gedanken gemacht mit viel liebe zum
detail der eingang zum beispiel ist echt
super geworden
herzlich willkommen im nagelneuen merkel
an
14 jahre ruhige hand werden hier
gewürdigt da können die tafeln sowie in
dieser woche noch so wütend vor
altersarmut warnen von sowas lässt sich
eine angela merkel doch nicht hetzen
deutschland hat immer noch keine
grundrente die dafür sorgen würde dass
jemand der sein leben lang im
niedriglohn geschuftet hat mehr bekommt
als einer der nie gearbeitet hat die
idee gibt es jetzt seit zehn jahren
schauen sie mal 2009 hieß das
alterseinkommen oberhalb der
grundsicherung 2012 zuschussrente 2013
solidarische lebens leistungs rente 2017
gesetzliche solidar ende 2019 respekt
rente bei der spd und grundrente bei der
cdu gekommen ist von alldem nichts
dazu passend hängt im nächsten raum ein
ölgemälde das das groko rentenkonzept
wunderbar zusammenfasst es heißt die
flaschen sammlerin
dieser raum trägt den titel zehn jahre
aufschwung was zum teufel haben wir
eigentlich daraus gemacht alles bilder
von deutschen schlaglöchern trotz vetter
steuer überschüsse lieben wir mit
unseren investitionen für verkehr und
infrastruktur unter dem oecd schnitt gut
dafür locken unsere schlaglöcher
inzwischen bade touristen aus aller welt
[Applaus]
[Musik]
es ist aufschwung und keiner merkt
beim mobilen internet hier deutschland
ganz aktuell auf platz 41
hinter moldawien rumänien und dem
libanon
kein witz 5 das hier ist die realität
nicht um wenn ich mal was mit dem handy
telefonieren möchte dann gehe ich zum
friedhof und da klappt das immer so da
hat man dich empfangen
aber ich kann ja nicht immer zum
friedhof rennen ja gut aber dafür wird
haben wir einen digital packt alle
schulen kriegen ipad richtig
leider haben zwei drittel der schulen
aber kein vernünftiges internets aber
ich sag mal wenn tisch wackelt kann man
so ein ipad natürlich super darunter
klemmen also sie würden schon sagen das
museum da in templin lohnt sich absolut
und das hier ist mein lieblings raum
das werk heißt warum wir angela merkel
noch vermissen werden
mein arzt hat mir verboten mich
weiterhin so aufzuregen
deswegen wollte ich euch allen einfach
nur einen schönen tag wünscht überall
lassen ihre risiken liegen und ihr
lastet slx ein beschissenes abo da
[Musik]